it will have offended and hurt people
Jeremy absolutely stands with and
respects everybody who has fought who
has lost their life in wounded in
fighting oppression and defending our
freedoms for many people the monarchy
singing the national anthem is a way of
showing that respect so should I they
have thunk that I think it would have
been appropriate and right and
respectful of people's feelings to have
done so yes so he should have done I
think so yes
well you're in my son to he were advisor
I would you like it's just sing it my
limbs are going to advise him to sing it
yes I would absolutely irrespective of
his news but I'm not sure that he didn't
sing it because he's a Republican he may
well have been thinking about something
else and he has said quite clearly that
he was simply standing there in
respectful sounds you quite often see
English footballers before the match not
singing in the game he was about to go
and do his big speech of the t's not
stops he was just thinking with that or
more more likely he was thinking about
the people he was commemorating
now this morning you said to the BBC my
overall view is we should probably would
be sticking to and potentially reducing
the overall benefit cap because we want
to get that down Jeremy Corbyn said the
reduction of the benefit cap has the
effect of socially cleansing many parts
of our cities now which is it I think
the bottom line is we're talking about
two different caps on because the
government has introduced two caps that
is the overall what they call structural
cap on overall welfare spending which is
cap right now at about 120 billion
pounds per annum and what our view is we
need to stick to that target and
potentially even reduce that tub is that
jeremy corbyn's of yes yes absolutely
i've discussed that with jeremy in his
view is that we want to see housing
benefit costs falling and we want to see
higher wages and we want to see lower
rent see Britain and that would drive
down overall spending on welfare but
they are benefit cap that he was talking
about is the separate cap on individual
households largely in London and that's
in respect of this twenty six to twenty
three thousand pound change they're
making and there is I think changing our
position because that's included in the
welfare bill that is coming before
Parliament shortly and we are going to
be under Jeremy now opposing the welfare
bill and therefore opposing the shift
from 26 to 23,000 and your personally
comfortable with that I think there has
to be a debate about this because I
think the truth is we still must support
overall reductions in welfare spending
because I think that is right and I
think that is what the country wants
so why did sugar let us say that he
wouldn't rule out campaigning to leave
the European Union well you would have
to ask chuck her that and I'm sorry has
he rules that then I mean you're
absolutely certain that he has ruled out
mr. Corbin has ruled out under any
circumstances campaigning to leave the
European Union jeremy has made it very
clear we're going to stay to fight
together for a better Europe we will be
campaigning to remain in the European
Union and in all circumstances under all
circumstances